actuellement les chiffres sont terribles
95 84 % des moins de deux ans regardent
la télévision une fois par semaine 43 %
des moins de deux ans ont taxé internet
qu'est ce qu'on fait sur internet quand
on a moins de deux ans je comprends pas
la consommation des écrans a augmenté de
54% chez les enfants on a beaucoup de
noms on a seulement 2 louis jean michel
maire non je dis non parce que si si ils
ont pas l'internet ou s'ils n'ont pas
d'écran qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
fait l'objet de s'en occuper c'est une
catastrophe
personne n'a d'enfants ici alors tous
ceux qui ont des enfants ils sont pas
hypocrite savent très bien que quand tu
rends d'une journée était fatigué bâton
enfant tue le col de vent devant son
ordi qui dit pas qu'il faut qu'ils
regardent des jeux violents des choses
comme ça il ya deux ans ah bon alors
deux en charge comprend page comme vous
je comprends pas l'histoire mais trois
quatre ans voilà comme ça après il ya
les jeux éducatifs sur internet et les
choses très bien fait qu'ils les aient
bay mais qui leur apprennent beaucoup
plus que si moi je les aide entraînant
des savates et cetera franchement ils
sont très bien
n'a pas d'enfant pas d'enfants mais qui
a beaucoup d'amis qui sont jeunes
parents et qui ont pris cette décision
j'ai médian de ne pas mettre leurs
enfants face à face à des écrans ça a
été très bien dit dans le sujet c'est
vraiment un enjeu de santé publique moi
j'suis pas pour interdire les choses de
base mais là en l'occurrence c'est de
l'avenir de nos jeunes français dont on
parle donc moi je pour le coup de
l'interdiction ne me convient d'en et le
truc des jeux d'éveil c'est vraiment la
libye parce que ça commence par les jeux
d'éveil et ça finit sur youtube après
donc pas répond pas sur steam d'heure à
deux ans que jean tigana sinon on
croiserait sophie ce serait
[Rires]
non plus pas d'interdiction les enfants
devant les écrans non parce que là la
question c'est faut-il interdire des
écrans à la question c'est parce que
c'est dangereux est-ce que c'est
dangereux oui donc je te rejoins
enterrement oui c'est dangereux mais de
l'intérieur des écrans pour moi c'est
pas la solution il faut limiter
l'utilisation encadrer le contenu mais
pas interdire pas plus de cinq six
heures par jour
jean-michel il veut nous faire le remake
d' orange mécanique avec les enfants en
fait en fait on voit des petits gamins
qui sont cloués sur le sur leur canapé
en train de regarder des séries c'est
comme les espèces de chênes télévision
qui sont pour les tout petits il ya des
chaînes avec des programmes baby pour
les jeunes pour les deux ans et je
trouve que c'est complètement scandaleux
les sharks occupe un enfant de deux ans
bah comme en occupant fait comme les
générations précédentes on s'occupe de
son gamin en fait là les écrans c'est
devenu la nouvelle nounou l'excusent
parcelles et voilà bah tiens je le mets
là parce que justement faut que je fasse
la bouffe le truc mais en fait comment
vous ai eu comment doser nos aînés en
fait pas trop ce mot
enfants avaient entre 1 et 5 ans bah
comment je fais moi en même temps quand
j'appuie sur mon truc pour recommander à
hubert comment je vais pas m'occuper de
mon gas en même temps je vois je vois
pas comment ce passe
non mais c'est vrai que le problème
c'est le dosage c'est toujours la même
chose moi j'ai trois garçons donc quand
le petit arrive plus ils sont élevées
dans la pratique puis son petit en fait
puis suivent les grands donc c'est
difficile quand il ya un ipad machin
d'interdît à l'interdire c'est
impossible pour moi c'est très compliqué
en revanche essayer d'éduquer et puis
moi ça m'a sauvé quand même des moments
des soirées enfin merci steve jobs quoi
mais vraiment donc voilà d'accord ce
soir ils ont besoin mais sauvé se sauver
des messages au développement mais c'est
vrai aussi qu'il faut s'occuper aussi de
son mec ou faut s'occuper son travail
donc deux temps en temps on peut
éventuellement laisser l'enfant devant
l'écran avec des contenus éducatifs moi
je l'aimé de devant baby einstein à
partir de huit mois et on met avec
l'ipad
j'ai mal quand parler on a vu un extrait
dans le mac d'une intervention de la
paix d'être admise du canda je vous
propose d'en voir d'en voir un autre en
entier heureusement on parle de dommages
réversible mais quand même alors le
premier risque c'est l'addiction parce
que les écrans apporte du plaisir sans
effort ce que notre cerveau humain
recherche qui les enfants sont beaucoup
devant les écrans quand ils sont tout
petits il ya ce moment là une carence
des changes et d'interaction qui donne
chez l'enfant des troubles de la
communication qui peut
tout à fait se confondre avec des
troubles de l'autisme mais c'est
complètement différent dans l'autisme
les troubles sont en partie seulement
récupérables et quand c'est lié aux
écrans c'est la cause est
environnemental et on peut récupérer
tout à fait bien chez un tout petit il
est quand même question de risque
comparable à l'autisme on parle de
risque pour la santé comme des retards
de motricité de langage une passivité un
trouble de l'attention perturbations du
lien d'attachement et perturbation des
repères au monde réel ce qu'il faut
c'est jean aimard mais c'est vraiment à
fond les enfants d'aujourd'hui sont plus
sont plus en difficulté ou attardé que
les enfants des années 50 ils sont six
éveillés ils sont en pleine forme la
maison fond il ya des études qui
démontrent le contraire alors j'espère
que mes enfants me regarde pas ce soir
et puis b montrent effectivement
l'intérêt des jeux interactifs aussi et
justement sur les troubles autistiques
aussi donc il ya des études qui sont
contradictoires sur le sujet c'est
toujours une chose c'est une question de
dosage c'est une question d' extrême si
le gosse il n'est pas dans six heures
sur le truc évidemment qu'il va devenir
complètement ok écoutons juliette sur ce
sujet bah oui moi je suis de la
communication bah oui le dosage en fait
et puis faut les éduquer aux écrans faut
encadrer faut limiter il ya des jeux
éducatifs et puis a décidé d émission et
éducative moi j'ai une copine
m&m et son gamin qui a trois ans devant
la table est allumé une série éducative
et puis le gamin ben il a trois ans il
connaît les dinosaures et koné de
tricératops
le tyrannosaure à doha il a trois ans
est super c'est quand même donc ça peut
quand même être positif je pense et puis
voilà mon enfant des années 90 j'ai
regardé tous les matins le club dorothée
les minikeums et je me sens pas plus
addicts écran que quelqu'un d'autre ou
plus bête que quelqu'un tente cela dit
c'est une question de dosage qu'est-ce
qu'on perdait beaucoup moins à l'époque
qu'aujourd'hui
je le réinvestis et dénicher les parents
parce que les parents pensent que leurs
enfants passent en moyenne 30 minutes
par jour seulement sur les écrans alors
qu'en réalité c'est au-delà du nord 30
c'est à dire que les parents ne sont pas
constamment derrière leurs enfants à
monitorer exactement le temps qu'il
passe derrière les écrans est en fait
leur donner comme ça libre accès à une
tablette à un ordinateur ça peut
potentiellement être dangereux qu'on ne
contrôle pas usage qu'on fait son enfant
par un contrôle parental maintenant en
plus sur la télé sur la table est donc
on peut soulever le problème a aussi
rejeté en est devenu à nous mêmes on est
plus incertain sont plus capables d'être
juge dans le dosage parce que nous même
adulte et agde ict a noté avec sûr qu'on
en ait en permanence alors que il ya
quelques années c'était pas le cas donc
même même nous en tant que parent on va
se dire bah tiens s'il reste une heure
et demi devant le dessin animé qui a
trois ans et c'est pas grave non mais
celle ci
a complètement raison parce que quand
moi je me vois tendance connue je peux
arrêter mon téléphone
en étant soi-même sans compter les vrais
oui c'est vrai que c'est compliqué il
faut pas lutter on peut vivre avec son
temps la société évolue comme ça tu vois
là y'a pas il n'y a pas de problème moi
je vois pas de problème gapa d'icebergs
devant nous bah on l'a dit c'est une
question de dosage et quand même chez
les enfants de moins de 5 ans
particulièrement chez les tout petits ça
peut avoir des dommages sur la santé sur
l'intention jura dont attention c'est à
l'extraire au moins cinq ans
interdiction complète pourquoi pas réglé
ça chez vous ça ne